the long-awaited and highly requested
new anime opera shirts are finally here
introducing bond love the pain created
by pro manga artist Cuusoo money and
also Eskin or all hailed the 1's Kannur
in his the one form also created by
Cuusoo mary if you want to get these new
shirts and support the channel at the
same time check out an email or comm
link in the description what is up
everybody its Anna Mak here for anime
uproar and today we will be talking
about the end of the seven deadly sins
manga after a bunch of chapters called
epilogue and a chapter called goodbye
seven deadly sins the story is now over
and you know everyone lived happily ever
after and all that stuff oh wait that's
not what happened
there was a huge twist at the end of
this chapter that changed everything
there might still be a whole other arc
coming if not more yes that's right I
can't believe how badly knock of a
Suzuki the creator of the seven deadly
sins just trolled all of us this is
actually hilarious to me I always
thought that there were way too many
unsolved mysteries left in the story to
have the manga and so soon
but I have to admit that with the
chapters called epilogue and all the
seemingly happy ending stuff even I
started to think that yeah maybe it's
over but hey at least we still have the
new season of the anime coming into fall
and all that stuff
but no I was just trolled huge we all
were and we need to talk about what
happened in Chapter 310 if you enjoy the
seven deadly sins content on this
channel you can leave a like to let me
know and if you're new to anime abroad
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell and of course this
video will discuss the latest
developments in the seven deadly sins
stories so please proceed with caution
manga spoilers ahead so the chapter
begins with Elizabeth preparing to leave
this mortal plane and entered a demon
realm together with Mellie Otis it's an
emotional farewell during which
elizabeth reflects on how much you will
miss her family and friends but she
feels that it is her destiny to follow
Mellie Otis so that they could finally
be together after 3,000 years of
suffering
who can blame them their love has
transcended time and overcome even
divine obstacles so the two of them
should definitely do whatever it takes
for them to be together meanwhile all
the sins are looking pretty glum because
of the fact that elizabeth emilio de
zara bout to leave and they asked merlin
about what the demon world is really
like merlin says that it's a polluted
land were powerful in Deraa demonic
beasts roam freely the impurities of the
demon world will rot away the souls and
bodies of members of other races except
the demons however because Elizabeth was
originally a goddess and because she
possesses unique magical abilities she
should be able to survive at least
that's what we are led to believe
although it is worth noting that the
current Elizabeth was born in a human
body so I don't know how confident I
feel that she would be able to survive
in the demon realm for an entire
lifetime nevertheless everyone has come
to accept Elizabeth's decision because
she was so steadfast and sure of herself
after she made it at first some of the
sins are surprised that Elizabeth would
be so brave and strong but Merlin
reminds them that during the last holy
war Elizabeth was part of stigma the
Alliance which fought against the demons
and hated all demons and yet Elizabeth
had the courage and strength to tell
them that Meletus the son of the demon
king is her lover and that he would be
joining their alliance now that I think
about it Elizabeth has definitely had a
lot of growth and development as a
character you could argue that at first
even though she is brave and definitely
committed to doing what's right she's
also kind of ditzy and naive however as
the story goes on and especially after
we learned her true identity Elizabeth
definitely becomes a more interesting
and impressive character overall we then
witnessed some heartfelt moments between
the sins when asked what he will miss
about this world
Meli Oda says that he would have liked
to see his kid and bonds kid fighting
and yeah that is the perfect Mellie
oldest answer and I can definitely see
bonds kids animal the oldest is kids
carrying on the friendly rivalry of
their fathers just like randomly arm
wrestling and fighting each other while
everyone else looks on in total
confusion
anyway King at the end and say oh but
what about their kid and I can't help
but also think about the potential of
Merlin and meskan or having a child
sometime in the future by the way which
kid do you think would be the strongest
and while we're on the topic don't
forget to follow us on twitter at anime
uproar and
vote for your favorite name for the Sun
of wrath the son of meliodas and
elizabeth that we created with the help
of pearl manga artist Kumari
we chose the four most popular and best
name ideas in our opinion and the
winning name will be determined by you
guys also a video about a new potential
seven deadly sins baby is currently in
the works so definitely stay tuned for
that
moving on meliodas then warns that even
if the fighting between the clans has
stopped for now this doesn't mean that
there will be a lasting peace between
the demons and the other races there is
still potential for another holy war to
break out in the future and already in
the holy wars of the past so many huge
sacrifices were made including Arthur
who meliodas believed would have made a
great King this implies again that
Arthur really died but I've always said
that I find the idea of Arthur being
dead and gone for good
unlikely knowing how much the seven
deadly sins has been inspired by our xxx
and legend I expected Arthur will return
in some shape or form before the series
is over that's just my hunch but feel
free to agree or disagree down in the
comments at this point meliodas
expresses remorse because he has spent
over 3,000 years trying to break
Elizabeth's curse neglecting other
people along the way including his
younger brother's elders however the
sins tell meliodas that he has saved
them all and that he is a good person
which is why Elizabeth fell for him in
the first place malleolus thanks them
and says that he is who he is today
because of the sins and they all share a
tearful emotional moment as the sins and
their friends approach agates to the
demon world that Merlin created the
seven deadly sins are officially
disbanded and everyone says their final
goodbyes outside the gate Mel Yoda's
asks Hawke if he wants to go with them
since Hawke is a creature from purgatory
so he would be able to survive in the
demon world but Hawke says that he first
wants to visit purgatory and see what
it's like because he now knows that
that's where he was born and he also
wants to erect a gravestone in memory of
his brother wild to be honest going off
to purgatory on his own doesn't sound
like the Hawke we know but Hawke is
growing as a character and he might
bring his mom along for the ride in
which case I am not worried for his
safety in the least as a symbol of her
resolve
Elizabeth walks towards the gate first
without turning back
meliodas lagging a bit behind turns
around to wave at everyone one last time
however in that very moment a massive
chunk of the cliff above them suddenly
collapses on top of Elizabeth everyone
is in utter shock especially Mellie Otis
as it appears that Elizabeth was crushed
beneath the rubble the name of the next
chapter and yeah you better believe that
there's a next chapter is and I quote
it's not over yet
the text on the final page says the
curse continues implied to notice
somehow failed to remove Elizabeth's
curse after all and wow what an absolute
troll we were taken on this ride I'm a
relatively happy ending for weeks
multiple chapters were teasing it and
then BAM
after everything Mellie Otis and
Elizabeth went through to break the
curse
Elizabeth apparently dies anyway now
this is the seven deadly sins so whether
or not Elizabeth
actually died is not clear although she
was definitely crushed under the rubble
on the final page we see her purse
crushed by the rocks and there also
appears to be blood around it so how
could this happen in Chapter 306 we saw
both curses the one place on meliodas
and the one place on Elizabeth given
visual form by Merlin and then being
visibly destroyed by Mellie Otis the
only thing that I can think of is that
the supreme deity is behind this latest
twist we've been talking for weeks about
how the supreme deity hasn't really
played a role in the story even though
she is a divine being whose power rivals
the demon king and it is possible that
either melioidosis demonic power was
unable to fully remove Elizabeth's curse
because the supreme deities power is
different from the demon Kings power or
perhaps the curse was actually removed
and someone deliberately did something
in order to cause the cliff to collapse
meaning that this was no random accident
related to the curse it is possible that
the supreme deity furious at the latest
turn of events and at the fact that the
curse she plays on Elizabeth has been
broken decided to finally emerge from
the celestial realm and face off against
Elizabeth and the seven deadly sins once
and for all either way it appears that
we might be in for another whole arc in
the story and my guess is that this will
be the long-awaited sue
Preem deity ark we are now learning more
about the demon realm as meliodas and
Elizabeth were preparing to live there
so it would make perfect sense for the
celestial realm to come into play at
this time as well
after all in Chapter 3:10 meliodas was
just talking about the fact that the war
between the different clans is not yet
over and even if the demon king has been
defeated for good as long as the supreme
deity continues to rule over the
celestial realm she will still want to
destroy all the demons the sins can't
expect a lasting peace by just defeating
the demon king in order to secure a
lasting peace they have to defeat the
supreme deity as well after all it takes
two to tango and both the demon king and
the supreme deity have been actively
encouraging members of their clans to
destroy each other for thousands of
years I have to admit that even though
I've been saying for a very long time
that we need to see the supreme deity
play a role in the story I was not
expecting this type of twist and I
honestly don't know what they're going
to do with Elizabeth that she actually
died meliodas now needs to wait for her
to be reincarnated again or will her
special goddess powers protect her so
she will actually survive the rubble
with maybe some injuries one thing is
for sure I can't wait to see what
happens in the next chapter let me know
what you guys think is Elizabeth really
dead and if not how do you think she
will survive also what do you think just
happened is the curse really still there
or did someone else cause the cliff to
collapse perhaps the supreme deity let
me know down in the comments I'd love to
hear from you especially now that I
myself don't know what to exactly make
of this man what a huge troll thanks
knockabout Suzuki very cool if you
enjoyed the seventh at least sense
content on this channel don't forget to
leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to anime uproar please
subscribe and hit that notification bell
also don't forget to check out our brand
new bond love the pain and esken or all
hailed the one shirts on anime out
Broadcom a huge thank you to all of our
anime uproar patrons for supporting our
work and when I especially thank our pro
hero tier patrons the one and only
Gilgamesh keelon and chubs is the man
and another huge thank you to our the
one to your patrons the ones
stand above all other clans including
ace Maddy Mac James a Lola madam Ingrid
ah and Ahmad and at the very pinnacle of
interdimensional greatness the tier
reserved only for legends a massive
thank you to baby ray the first-ever
disciple of Lord to ego himself if you
guys feel that our content provides
value for you and you want to support
more be sure to check out our patreon
link in the description even donating a
single dollar will give you access to
our anime up for patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching I really appreciate it and
until next time see us space cowboys
[Music]